la casa blanca lo describe como una
llamada a la acción ya la
responsabilidad de las empresas de
estadounidenses el presidente de estados
unidos joe biden insta a las compañías
de su país a reforzar sus defensas
digitales contra posibles ciberataques
rusos
la magnitud de la capacidad de
cibernética rusa es bastante consecuente
y se está acercando el gobierno federal
está haciendo su trabajo para prepararse
pero bajo nuestra ley el sector privado
todos ustedes deciden en gran parte las
medidas de protección que tomarán o no
de bailén dijo que los ciberataques
forman parte del libro de jugadas de
rusia y a washington le preocupa que las
infraestructuras claves de eeuu puedan
estar en peligro aunque los asesores de
ciberseguridad de la casa blanca dicen
que no hay pruebas hasta el momento
aseguran que han notado actividades
inhabituales como el escaneo de sitios
web en busca de vulnerabilidades por
tanto advierten a las empresas que estén
atentas a cierta actividad preliminar
que estamos viendo y eso es lo que
compartimos en un contexto clasificado
con las empresas que pensamos que
podrían verse afectadas lo que en sus
accesos digitales dificultan el trabajo
los hacker hagan que se esfuercen más se
ha aconsejado a las empresas de
estadounidenses que tomen medidas una de
éstas es hacer copias de seguridad de
sus datos y activar la autenticación
multifactor